talk about pizza you put me and do you
take the subway when you're in New York
what's the like typical snack at a
baseball game and there's go get a dog
hi everyone my name is jag Wallace and
I'm a dialect coach here in Hollywood
today I'm gonna be trying to find out
who has the authentic New York accent hi
my name's Rachel and I'm from New York
hi my name is Hayley and I'm from New
York what up my name is Zeus and I'm
from New York now this is a tricky one I
don't think he's gonna have any idea
that I'm the person from there are lots
of variation within the city of New York
when it comes to New York accents I'm
banking on the fact that I'm from the
hood of New York and he doesn't know
anything about that potentially one of
the pitfalls for our fakers out there
could be going too hard into a
stereotypical sound that you would think
of like hot dog rather than by keeping
it subtle and keeping it natural let's
see who we've got today and let's hope I
get it right
all right so let's start with our first
victim of the day what is your name sir
my name is Zeus how long have you been
in LA up three years what's your
favorite thing about New York Vegas go
ahead get a little chopped cheese or
something like that the bodegas like you
only have them out here in New York I
mean in LA like that so I can't miss
that
well what do you like to do it's like
spend a lot of time with my daughter I
added a lot watch a lot of movies like
kung-fu movies and things like that
what's the like typical snack at a
baseball game families go get a dog
there are various characteristic New
York sounds coming out when they're
talking that last word especially it
kind of shows the difference between the
hot and the dog whereas in other accents
they merged it goes hot dog has two
different sounds so you know you didn't
trip up there you also have quite a lot
of words that you're using the right
sides at the right places so seems kind
of natural a little bit of tension
nervousness but again I'm judging the
world accents so yeah I'll keep thinking
about you I can get you to stand back in
the light
let's try our next person hello again
hello what is your favorite thing to do
I like to do I like to go to shows a lot
what do you miss most being in LA from
New York the people probably it's very
different on the west coast talk about
pizza put me I'm gonna Meegan do not
have vegan pizza with like a cauliflower
crust and my cashew cheese so what do
you like to eat there a lot of fruits
and vegetables that's pretty much the
majority of what I eat I eat a lot of
rice a lot of beans a lot of tacos
because I don't know what
briefly tell me about some of your
tattoos they are a different mix of
things this is my science on I probably
have like three different X's on my body
somewhere as I said at the start there's
a plethora of accents you can have when
you're from New York at the moment there
are no distinguishing features that
immediately place it in that city but
again she's talking very naturally it
doesn't seem like she's necessarily
putting on an accent for this and yeah
what do you like most about the city
thanks for path yeah what'd you do that
I like to read there you said you're
enacted you watch a lot of shows when
you over there my favorite musical right
now is Natasha appear and the comment of
1812 I went on the name what do you like
about it so much it's a simple plot but
it's also like very compelling and do
you take the subway when you're in New
York
definitely the subway even though it's
yeah see if you are doing some dishes
what's the thing that you wipe
everything with a quoi what do you walk
in the streets if it's not a cat on a
leash it might be a dog if something
goes Kapow after like a timer it might
be a a bomb tell me the four kind of
relatives you would generally have in
like a family if there were two parents
of two children ma dad sister brother
and what of the sister and brother in
relation to the parents the son and
daughter the joy of the Internet is that
you can pause and rewind this and listen
to everything they say ten times over
but as a dialect coach you don't get
that joy you have to just listen out
there little things so that's what I've
been doing this time the person that has
the most signature sounds with a typical
New York accent so far would be Zeus
Rachel is talking very naturally she
seemed to be doing something extra with
her DS with Haley she's got some of the
signature sounds seems a little more
reluctant to speak this time so I don't
know if this might be can we get to the
deathmatch round we have 30 seconds left
with each person it's fine around it's
my last chance to glean any information
I can and see if they're really from
where they say they got I have 30
seconds with each press
let's go in reverse order if you are
going into court you need this person
with you oh boy yeah if you open the
morning you go to take Donuts
you have your doughnut and you have
coffee and is it cold
usually it's hot those two words
together hot coffee I think that's it
what are the five boroughs feel like I'm
on Family Feud five boroughs okay Staten
Island Manhattan Brooklyn Queens the
Bronx out of all of those we're a JLo
and cardi B from the Bronx mm-hmm if
you're in Manhattan and there's no
fruits or vegetables like in their raw
form what would you eat hummus okay we
were talking about hot beverages earlier
can you tell me the three main kind of
genres hi chocolate tea and coffee
excellent thank you all right is it on
the line
one of the things you have to understand
with accent is that what do they be
useful are they being used in real life
are they being used to convince yourself
that you are someone else in this case
if I'm not correct that person has done
a really good job of doing all the
things they need to in order to sound
like they're from where they are from my
final guess for this it's gonna be Zeus
[Music]
there aren't very many signature sounds
in your accent I can usually tone it
down but I tried not to tone it down too
much but I I also went around a lot of
your words Harry I'm a dialect coach and
I was fooled I feel good and bad that he
didn't catch me
good because I fooled him bad because I
want everyone to know I'm from New York
he got me on the hot coffee thing I we
both like made eye contact and it was
just like oh oh everyone knows what's
happening here I think I did it because
uh
one I'm actually from Norfolk Virginia
too I used to spend summers in Long
Island with my cousins I just channeled
my inner wu-tang and I'm saying like the
womb the womb was strong with your baby
but he did ask me about the the hot dogs
I was like I he's trying to see how I
pronounced the word dog so I just ran
through that didn't sweat a bit
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]